oh your lead man i mean do you want to
pick back up with the norway stuff
because we gotta
because you know okay now we're live
okay we are by the way we are officially
live
we are live uh what is this 39 episode
yep yeah are we live or no you're
pointing fingers at us okay we're good
bring it in don't worry about it bring
it in okay so listen very interesting
start to the morning today
baby yes very weird morning say hello to
everybody
there you go what's your name tell us
tell them who you are
brandon do video edits okay good thank
you think about it you don't think about
it this is a double double
very very weird uh morning for uh for uh
for us today elaborate elaborate what's
happened over the last half hour i think
it's fair to say i had the worst egg
whites in my life
ever that mickey brought it's not
something better or worse than yesterday
no no i mean it's equally that chicken
whoever that chicken was that that
gave birth to that egg white was
horrible that's the worst egg what i've
ever had yeah
every morning you do egg whites yeah if
i'm at the office yeah you kind of give
like a no
no no up in your mouth that exactly that
egg white was legit terrible yeah
and then we had the um paul is wearing
his
uh superman glasses clarquette paul can
you come and show your face real quick
show that beautiful over here so people
know with his beard the the glasses
guys let us know if he's got a customer
he's got
he's got the full on take a look at the
camera give him a smile
yeah don't forget the keyboard i don't
know he's got the seriously he's got the
superman thing going on paul escarsica
there you go buddy just been a weird
morning yeah do we want to address the
elephant in the room
you can address it if you want to
where's mario where is mark mario
mario mario where are you mario our
our our faithful leader
mario demanding mario that's the tone
sets the president
everybody beats down so you know
where you sit in the corner with us no
listen
let me tell you one thing about mario
mario mario's worked
probably i don't know he's working
harder than anyone oh
yeah for how long now god knows right 15
years straight
but no day talking about specifically
setting this whole thing up
so uh uh we'll let him you know when he
gets in here maybe he just wants to
everyone deserves a day off everybody
mario just so happened to do it on the
day that we're doing our big podcast
where we have kai
he's a leader we love him listen we look
to him just
to work in this environment you have to
have thick skin or else
yeah it's going to be rough it's a rough
environment specifically
valuetainment specifically because you
know it's it's it
you know it's tough this is by the way
this was exactly how it was in the army
at our unit
if you were at our unit and you wanted
to hang out with us on the weekend you
had thin skin we were the bad
worst people to hang out but if you had
thick skin yeah we were part of the
thick skin community and we had a good
time together anyways
let me tell you my first month of
valuetainment cried in the corner for a
moment i'm
straight i'm like i can't remember i
remember i had you now
baby yes well let me let me read what
somebody said yesterday
to go there i think it's important to
the two percent of the audience no no
this is actually 20
of the audience natalie june commented
yesterday this is so mom's now we are
she comments this is so off topic but
how is adam single
so then i responded great question he's
looking for the right person are you
interested
she says i am single and he's gorgeous
intelligent and above all
he seems to have a big heart he seems
like such a great guy i followed him on
ig with the same photo it's real i swear
and then i would love to get to know me
tonight you know it is what it is the
rest of it is for you can i be the ring
bearer
yeah yeah thank you natalie thank you
for uh
valuetainers out there for the it's good
love and respect
we'll see you at flanagan yeah see you
at the gecko
people watch our podcast like what the
hell is this gecko so
so so first of all uh to our friends in
plano
okay i'm supposed to be in texas next
week for me yeah with jose guyton tj all
those guys and i'm going to
louisville to be with sao paulo's vargas
and everybody which they're going to
have um
this is your squad if you don't know
those names this is like yeah but tito
well i think ortiz is going to be there
next week t ortiz and
uh uh who's the football player the
quarterback tim tebow's going to be in
uh which by the way that's a very big
time
and tim tebow on stage together kibo's
going to be there
and the guys you know tebow's probably
one of the best motivational speakers in
the world
one hell of a one quarterback so i'm
sitting here i'm like okay let me see
what i got award next week for dallas
and i look at the weather it says a low
of three degrees
okay a low of three degrees and morale
sends me she says no you have it wrong
it's a low of one degree
let me pull up the weather i went to
look at the coldest day ever
in plano yeah it's minus seven degrees i
say plano go for it
that's what i said break the record go
up right there kind of like us and the
lego let's go to minus eight first
two first yeah it's it's uh forecasted
hey look at that
monday two degrees that's ridiculous to
be out two degrees but if you guys are
not familiar with plano that's just
outside and for the european audience
this is not celsius right
oh you you see how you had the crickets
there too yeah that was the european
union
this is here mario
he's in the house he's in the house he's
in the house okay mario see here mario
all right
all good all good allow me to say
on behalf of the south florida welcoming
committee it's 75 it's sunny it's
gorgeous
go [ __ ] yourself plano
you said it i didn't i lived there for
five years kids went school over there
we have to put the disclaimer out there
i loved it it was very good to us but
uh that's your uh uh okay that's true
i'm sorry
okay all right so let's let's let's get
into it so we got a lot to talk about
we got a lot of topics to talk about
robert f kennedy jr officially got
kicked off of instagram
okay so that's pretty interesting
permanent star twitter
in-store twitter twit instagram but not
facebook
but not facebook but not twitter just
instagram okay so
because that's where he's most active
he's very active on instagram we'll talk
about that here in a minute
uh but by the way we got we got a we got
an email this morning from
andrew yang's uh yeah that they wanna
they wanna be on that what did they say
exactly no no just say hey
would you be interested and we're gonna
go back and forth and see if it makes
sense for us of andrew young
that'd be cool you know what i i
commented on the poster at the other day
he put a video up
and you know there are certain policies
you can have a battle with
but the guy as an individual you got to
like the guy like
the guy is a skateboarder he's sitting
there in new york playing the piano i
commented i said i hope you beat de
blasio i'm rooting for you
is de blasio running again well you know
whatever the point is i hope you win
because i want
everything to be changing with new york
with what de blasio the message made et
cetera et cetera imagine if he wins in
new york
and chamot wins in california that's
that's cool
i think they're very similar by the way
very likely yeah yeah
gang is number one i like it but that's
the mayor there's a big difference
between
that's a tougher task than i think it is
a tougher task but he's got
he's got silicon valley in his corner
shaman's got silicon valley in this
corner shamans got the young
entrepreneurs and this is quite likely
likable guys smart guy on the other
people really like him in california
he's definitely uh doing a great job
right
did you just frickin say that's good you
might get uh
they're they're closing in on one point
maybe we'll start off with that we'll
start off with that we'll start off so
just
because of you are you part of the yang
gang is that what you're saying i didn't
say that i do
not gang yang yang yeah yeah but okay i
think
i think he'll he'll be very good for the
city i really think he'll be a very good
mayor i actually think he would be a
good mayor
uh uh i'm on kind of the same
wavelengths as pat
yeah yeah yeah there's interesting stuff
with him and then there's i you know i
you know what i'd want i'd want to
yesterday i talked to kiyosaki
and you did an interview with him which
is coming up pretty insane that the uh
adam's got an interview
but i was speaking to him yesterday and
uh maybe i'll bring that up here in a
minute when we get into it but
he said what do you think about what's
going on right now with uh having to
be careful with what you say says my
team's constantly trying to protect me
for consuming sometimes i tweet some
stuff that i shouldn't be tweeting et
cetera et cetera
and and we'll cover that because it's a
strange time you're living you have to
be very very
careful and selective with the words you
use because they can come after you in
no time but we'll cover that
i don't want to bring up any bad you
know food stuff but it's kind of like
you need to walk on eggshells
these days your eggs were just you know
terrible what happened what happened
when i ate the eggs by the way i mean
pat
eats as egg whites every morning before
he
last podcast he said something was up
with those eggs i'm not sure
uh so you know how you take the paper
towel you put it on top of the pizza
two to two degrees mickey did that with
egg whites yeah
that doesn't make sense i've never heard
of that before so she didn't do it this
morning
she didn't do it this morning so you had
two bites of egg whites and then you
gave the old
that chicken's out of business okay all
right so uh is norway's socialists we're
going to talk about that today because
their minimum wage we we're going to
actually look at a lot of the minimum
wage from different countries yeah the
time we spent yesterday i thought it was
very interesting with what we came up
with
um most business friendly countries okay
at the top
is one that we'll cover here in a minute
uh minimum wage stats
um smart cart uh startup caper is
helping retailers compete with amazon by
digitizing
the in-person shopping experience reddit
raised another quarter of a billion
dollars and double its valuation
to six billion just because of the
gamestop saga what a what a
in 30 days you go from 3 billion to 6
billion you didn't sell any product
you just have wall street bets help you
increase your value by 3 billion that's
pretty big
they might have been the biggest winner
of the whole situation i do agree with
you
sales street bets was really big for
them yeah i do agree with you read it
overall yeah
salesforce says the nine to five work
day is debt and will provide three new
ways for employees to work including the
possibility of working from home
forever okay our favorite coin pronounce
it for me please
doge doge coin goes viral has the crypto
market lost
all sanity and the ceo made comments
himself that will cover him and half of
gamestop buyers
are first-time traders never have traded
before we'll cover that the battery
kai's got extensive research that he's
done on battery
uh in the market the history of battery
we'll get into that as well u.s stock is
a bubble
new york allowing indoor sports this is
a good sign at a certain capacity and
they have certain restrictions
aoc says it was a mistake that biden
doesn't pay off the student loan debt of
50 000. twitter says trump wouldn't be
allowed back even if he ran again in
2024 for president dems on house
committee
15 minimum wage gavin newsom et cetera
et cetera we've got a few other things
that we'll cover and then mark cuban
uh didn't play the national anthem the
nba said it is a requirement for us to
play
the national anthem let's go to gavin
newsom
page eight everybody if you're listening
to this it's like you're a church go to
page eight please of your notes
go to psalms eight
line six right okay here we go
governor newsome has two potential
challengers for governor as recall
petition nears 1.5 million
supporters have until march 17 2021 to
collect
1.495 709 signatures that's 1.495
million
709 signatures needed to trigger a
recall election
as of february 3rd organizer
announced that they had collected more
than 1.3 million signatures by the way
they've already collected over 1.3
million they only need 190 thousand
started in like november decisions
that's a scary thought that's too quick
california's won the nineteenth i might
have been a little like two a day or two
older i think they're up to one point
four i
i think you're right mario can you pull
up to see how many signatures they've
gotten
uh for uh uh what do you call it recall
newsome yeah
california's won the 19 states that
allowed for allows for citizens to
recall elected officials according to
the california secretary of state
website the petition needs at least
1.495 million
or 12 percent of the 12 million votes uh
in the last
election for governor on monday
conservative commentator mike
cernovich announced that he would run
against newsome if a recall vote
is successful in the state cernovich
announced came
during a live stream video posted on his
twitter account where he said the
question is why i would run for governor
and the answer this answer is pretty
simple
in addition to cernovich billionaire
venture capitalist shamath
uh has suggested that he plans to run
against newsom shamaat has yet to
publicly announce his bid for governor
but he has been very critical of newsom
and has shown his support
for the recall petition is this well
deserved for newsome to be
recalled kicked out and not be the
governor of california what are your
thoughts i mean we've been talking
you're you're born in i'm sorry raised
in california
24 years you're your mom is from
california i know you're from norway but
you have family in california cali roots
i'm a florida boy so i'm not really
too up to speed on california politics
but
you know we've been since the basically
started the podcast since
everything that started with the
pandemic we've been covering what
gavin newsom has been doing and it
hasn't been pretty there
we are you know we jokingly called him
the u-haul sales person of the year
everyone's getting the hell out of
california
and it seems like they are getting very
very very close
to this uh what is it recall for the
election
um my question is this just to kind of
give the other side of the coin because
it'd be very easy to bash newsome you
you see on
you know even on snl they call them you
know you know
an inflatable sex doll it's just kind of
like this robotic
uh what he kind of reminds me of um
speaking of uh michael bury what was uh
what's uh who plays michael bury in the
movie
christian bale christian bell's
character in uh
help me out here american psycho with
the j the hair gel it kind of has that
vibe going on
you tell me but my where i want to go is
this is
i can see that you can see that a little
bit right just kind of like this
soulless
sex doll kind of a guy mario you might
want to pull this up if you can
gavin newsome approval ratings in
california i'd love to see if we can
find
that data obviously he's a very
unlikable person he's getting a lot of
hate
uh i saw a person just basically mocking
him on
youtube yesterday and it was actually
spot on
i want to know when uh this recal this
election would be
and what his current approval ratings
are because
you might get 1.5 people to be a part of
this recall
um but if if he has high approval
ratings in the state of california
it might sort of be a moot point do we
have something here does that say 52
that's job approval job approval rating
that's what i'm looking for yeah
so his job approval rating is 52
that's not horrible bill de blasio's is
way lower than that in new york
so i mean if you're if you're using are
you a little shocked right now you
if you had to guess where did you think
his job approval would be in the 30s
at least maybe the 40s 40s i mean trump
hovered somewhere between
40 and 45 38 and 45 his whole presidency
i don't think he ever cracked 50.
newsome we talk a lot of trash about him
yeah and i'll i'll give it up to you now
but he's
still above 50 percent so i'm actually
surprised to see that's where he is so
meaning
for all the pandemic stuff that he's
doing all the stuff the u-haul jokes
there's a large contingency that says no
he's doing a pretty good job
here's here's a question for you here's
a question for you what is the most
liberal state in america
boom you got it cali maybe maybe boston
maybe massachusetts maybe hawaii
california california is probably the
most liberal state in america
okay think about san francisco think
about you know
lots areas in l.a think about santa
monica think about california is the
most liberal state but not not way up
north right
i mean that's when it gets a little bit
more conservative
or even closer to the east side of the
state near nevada i agree
but it's it's probably the most liberal
it's the highest taxes in america number
one new york
new york is i think number eight uh the
best taxes in america is tennessee
but so if california was a country
california wouldn't be america
if california was a country california
would be france california would be
a more liberal uh politically which
means 50
rating is is doesn't is not surprising
to me because it's like yeah that's the
country where most of them want more
social programs most of them want more
of somebody on that side so yes of
course it would be a 50 you're not
surprised by that
zero that doesn't do anything for me
that doesn't do anything for me
all it does is is a simple thing look
right here
there's a guy last year right this
community right across it's called royal
palm
literally 200 yards from us right royal
palm okay
one guy his name is david i believe do
you know how much he sold
in the last 12 months in royal palm how
much real estate i showed it to you yeah
you said he sold like 700.
no no no crazy can you grab the brochure
out of my office it's the big blue
brochure
office you can go to sam grab the big
blue brochure out of my
it's going to be a nice advertisement
for him big blue brochure out of my
office
uh that has royal palm properties you'll
see it he was the guy in royal palm
737 million dollars of home sold
in one community wow in one community
so one year in one year in 12 months
okay
in 12 months in one year almost
everybody you run into here when you
talk to them
how you doing are you how you doing you
know so where are you from jersey where
are you from new york where are you from
why why would i stay in new york i love
new york but why would i stay there new
york's only place i go to for vacation
okay here it is this is this is uh thank
you this is the
royal palm community i think i'm hoping
i said the number right
okay i don't know if i got the name yeah
you got it yep his name is david
okay how much did he sell 737 million
dollars from january 1st
to december 31st okay we're talking
about in a two-year period
he sold 737 million dollars why people
are leaving
they're leaving new york to come here
okay people are leaving california
you go to texas how many people were
your neighbors when you talked to where
are you from california where are you
from california where are you from
california
there are people that don't want to
leave california yeah there are people
that
just want to make sure california
improves there are people that are so
deep rooted they're like listen man i
don't want to leave this place
i want to stay here i just don't want
this guy to be my governor
and i want policies to change there is
that community that's sick of it right
you know out of the 1.4 million votes
that he got for the recall a third are
moderate democrats
we talked about it last time and it's
getting very close if it's getting to
this point here that this is going to be
taking place
it wouldn't be a nice thing for him to
take place because of many of the
democrats when they're looking at their
lineup
of who could be the potential future
president he's on that list
he's on a list of a future president oh
absolutely he's on the list
are you kidding me he's on a top five
he's on a short list
of somebody that could be he looks like
it he has a yeah california i just you
know he has got that
raspy voice he's a gruff voice but he's
he's a track you ever see him given
the answers the way he talks like he's
polishing he knows the game
he's been in the game he looks the part
he looks the part but he talks he
the whole game he knows right he's a
politician he's a politician
i don't know if this is going to be a
good look for him if he ever runs for
office
i don't think this is going to be good
recall no way i don't think it's going
to be a good look for him if he gets the
record how many people do you know that
sign that recall
a lot really oh a lot how many people do
you know that says no that's my guy
i would never you you do a few okay i
actually because you've got
roots in california you know thousands
of people there oh a few a few people
that say no i think it's okay i think we
should let him go he's not as bad as
trump he's not as bad as this he's not
as bad as that at least he's not cuomo
where he let
you know he didn't give the right facts
about people being in the old folks home
or you know the no no
and people died nursing homes at least
he didn't do that it's all about at
least at least so there is that
community
they're giving them the benefit a lot of
people are sick of it do you think
there's an underground
like the the people that are voting to
recall him is it kind of the same
underground that started flocking behind
trump
in 2016 like the silent majority look
you know
i got a call from one of my mentors
advisors very successful president of a
multi
hundred billion dollar company uh uh and
he's in his seventies and we had a great
conversation together he says look in
life
here's how it works he says you're gonna
have battles
there's gonna be little fights that
happens all the time with you and
somebody with you and family with you
and a friend with you and all that stuff
he says the goal is to try to get the
battles to be done somebody wins you
move on everybody goes about their
business right
he says then there's wars when there is
a war
you have to know that every country has
to defend themselves okay
i have to defend me you have to defend
you and you know there's going to be
some
casualties at the end of the war no
matter what if you go to war there's
casualties
he said then there's nuclear wars when
it's nuclear wars
it lasts a long time and the amount of
blood in your hands going to be a lot
last 12 months politically was a nuclear
war and
the way they went after trump it doesn't
end there it's not like there's no
residual effects to it there's
still going on right now it's nothing
it's nothing the residual effects of the
last 12 months is not a one-year
residual effect
the residual effects of the last 12
months is a 10 20 year residual effects
are you kidding me
let me put it to you this way the
residual effects of the last 12 months
could be
25-year effects of a barren trump type
of residual effect
like you have to know you offended my
dad
so so this what they did last year may
be like hey
it's called you know oh yeah so you did
that to trump we're gonna do this to
newsom we're gonna do this
so so they started it and said for today
they started a nuclear
war and it's not you took trump off
watch how long it takes until the next
damn president
just what are you going to say no so
they started
a nuclear war and now they're impeaching
who in the world
cares about a former president being
impeached like let me say this one word
like okay
it's like saying i'm gonna fire an old
employee that i've already let go of
what are you talking about so you
understand like you came you served your
six months or 12 months
a year later i want to change it from
that you just did your time and your
contract you wrapped it up no no i want
to change it to i
fired you what are you talking about
no one in the world cares about a former
president being impeached move on
he's a former one-term president what's
worse than being a one-term president
how many one-term presidents do we have
been impeached twice you know what it is
to be a one-term prayer what's worse
than a one-term president
jimmy carter one term senior one term
there is nothing worse than being a
one-term president nothing for a
president are you saying they should not
even prove no
any of the illegals are already bad
enough but
since they're doing it they just have to
be prepared
for the nuclear war in the world of
politics
are you saying that they should i'm not
i'm not saying that this is we're this
is conversation right here
should they not pursue what's good
because they just started this you know
second impeachment trial everything
that's going on should they or should
they not yeah it's not shitty or should
they not okay
a long time ago i had to you know in my
20s it was always about
no but they're wrong no but they're
wrong no but they're wrong like listen
after
plenty of books to read and mentors
counsel all this stuff
dude you don't need to win everything
certain things you just
you just gotta let go of it this is not
worth it this is embarrassing
why do you think they're going after
themselves it's i think it's a little
too much i think it's like
proven a point he's the first to be
impeached twice do you think there's a
any part of it where they're trying to
make sure that he's barred from
from running i think that's the big one
trying to put the nail in the conference
100 that's it but i tell you one i
talked to oliver north
yesterday or two days ago yesterday i
and i said who's your number one
candidate for 2024
he said mike pence i said okay i said
do you think trump should run in 2024
he said no absolutely not he says
they're going to destroy his businesses
they're going to go after him he says
what he needs to be focused on right now
is to take care of his family
because it's going to be pretty ugly
this is all of our notes you'll see i'm
prepping
obviously i'm uh you know and by the way
i'm familiar with oliver north yeah um
famous in the early 80s this when was
the iran contra 8184 like
reagan's second he was famous for a big
trial
on capitol hill yep you know for those
of you who are not familiar got arrested
for those you know
five people were not arrested guilty
okay so he was one of them poindexter i
think was another one
uh of five cia agents and a couple other
names
this is like the equivalent i'm i'm not
exact but like this is a watergate-ish
benghazi type in the news
type of it was like holy moly oliver
north on trial yeah so it was a 30
million dollar
money that they got to work with i think
a country that they were protecting the
country
you know nicaragua but it's a small
region of it and they took out of that
again i you can go verify this 18
million
to buy weapons for iran and give weapons
to so it was a very
uh interesting thing that took place
this is also on the tail end of the cold
war so you have the whole russia
or communism versus capitalism and and
the ideologue
ideological fight as well yeah yeah so
so the whole challenge is you know
oliver north said i don't think he needs
to run i think he needs to take care of
his family but
the point i'm trying to make here was
newsome i'm not surprised
you you caused a nuclear war so when you
cause a nuclear war there's going to be
a few what
casualties newsom is going to be one of
them
is a casualty because of the nuclear war
and i think they knew they're going to
have casualties
i think they knew they were going to
have casualties this if it happens
you potentially eliminated one of your
future presidents
and and he's a high draft pick by the
way very high traffic he's the top five
candidate
and the thing with you know as with
anything it's a lot of it has to do with
optics
optics right so you know again like we
said
polish good looking you know kind of
looks like uh christian bale's character
in american psycho hair gel you know
kind of
but when he's shutting down all the
wineries
and then he apparently owns a winery and
the one
his one freak you own a winery bro oh
his was one winery is open
and he's yeah and he's they're drinking
french laundry mat restaurant party
distancing like you're getting it's very
easy to be like get this douche bag out
of here it's just very easy to feel this
i think that's the word though i think
that's a word to describe it and look
you you knew you knew folks like that in
high school who liked guys like that
you know behind closers you're like dude
just stop i saw you're so annoying right
you get over yourself buddy you know
you're you're not as
you know uh amazing as you think you are
it's a bit annoying the way you are
as a californian if you're watching this
i'm actually curious right now
we have 178 thumbs up 233 thumbs up one
thumb down
okay i'm curious if you're watching this
recall thumbs up smash thumbs up if you
say
he needs to get out we need to recall
and we need to move on and get a shamath
or somebody else
no he's doing a good job let's keep him
in there press thumbs down i'm curious
thumbs up
out thumbs down it's fine let's just
keep him in there continue you were
saying
as a californian because you keep
obviously a closer tab on california
politics
who do people in california dislike more
newsome or la mayor eric garcetti
it's it's not even a question on how it
is i mean newsome's on their list
number one because newsome's a governor
it's not it's an unfair uh
it's like saying who do people like more
a high school basketball player or an
nba player newsom is a nba player newsom
is playing on the big leagues one of 50.
how many mayors you got in america of
course it's a bigger mayor you're mayor
of l.a i get it but garcetti bloomberg
you know it's it's uh
you know it's
like uh newsome probably influences
garcetti more than garcetti influences
i agree yeah i agree and by the way
garcetti is a more yes sir person
bloomberg is not bloom de blasio is not
de blasio fights yeah uh cuomo cuomo is
like dude what are you talking about let
the amazon people come and put their
jobs here
no it's not fair it's like what is what
is the matter with you right
so so garcetti and newsome are on the
same page de blasio and cuomo they're
not on the same page mario while we're
on the topic would you
would you would you find out bill de
blasio approval ratings in new york i'd
be curious to know fifty one percent was
what no no no fifty one percent
yeah bill de blasio approval rating
like no way it's is it at 50 i feel like
this is awesome
2019 article no no go back go go current
you know that when you put current there
that was good
you put current right before approval
you did that with uh newsom yeah
it's my spelling right there yeah i saw
that i saw that
a little over 51 march 26 yeah they
don't have it out there okay
so so anyways you know we'll see what's
going to happen with this in the state
of california whether he's going to be
gone or he's going to stay but
uh very soon we are going to find out
exactly the results on this fyi we got a
few
people i want to give a shout out to
george just gave five bucks and pb to do
a reaction on tom mcdonald
song fake woke give an opinion he's also
one called canceled okay
i you don't want to hear me sing but i
am i'm somebody that sings a lot but
privately
welcome to mark savant media welcome to
south florida pbm fam have you started
playing
the clubhouse yet it's the future talk
radio we'd love to have you in one of
the rooms honestly i'm on clubhouse but
i've not done a single room on cloud i'm
interested in knowing yeah we ought to
do one
we ought to do one i hear a lot about it
yes you haven't done anything nicole
cirino recalled gavin newsom signed the
petition rand paul tulsa gabbard 2024
rest in peace on to gemini racism solved
okay
15 bucks over here charles moscarella
bet you can't have presidents thinking
they
can do crazy things just before leaving
office he was still president during the
insurrection
okay so okay that's what we got right
there all right let's continue
next topic next topic what we got is
let's go into nba nba now
requires to play the national anthem
after the dallas mavericks halt
ritual specifically mark cuban decided
to stop playing the national anthem
in the game this is something that the
nba has been doing for a long time the
league announcement comes after the news
that dallas maf sees playing the
national anthem prior to home games this
season at the direction of owner mark
cuban the mavs have not played
the national anthem before any home
games this season a spokesperson
told nbc the announcement from bass
seems to contradict a previous statement
from nba spokesperson tim frank who told
the nbc news that
teams are permitted to run their
pre-game operations as they see
fit through league policy nba requires a
stand for national anthem according to
the nbc sports nbc commissioner adam
silver hasn't strictly enforced the rule
allowing players to kneel during the
anthem in the nba bubble last season so
uh you know mark cuban decides to not
play the national anthem
i don't know if well we watched the
interview together yesterday with uh
the girl from espn i don't know her name
but she's always on
rachel nichols rachel nichols and he
said look it's not that i wasn't
planning on doing it we just didn't know
if we were going to do it or not we were
just kind of listening to the audience
and some of them thought it wasn't a uh
something that represented their
community they didn't want it to be
played others wanted to be played
so we just kind of start over and now
we're going to go back and playing it so
what are your thoughts about the
national
anthem and mark cuban i mean let me just
start off with mark cuban i know you're
listening
play the damn national anthem
i'll say it again play the damn national
anthem we're here in america
the flip side to that is you want to
kneel
you want to do the colin kaepernick
thing cool
but play the got national language tell
me why tell me we're in freaking america
what are we talking about what do you
mean by that so what do you mean by that
we're in america what's the big deal i
mean
like listen obviously this is the
argument that they're making so i'm
trying to see what you're arguing i mean
obviously i'm i
you know there's certain things i'm a
little left on certain things i'm a
little right on right
but where are we in the conversation
where no more national anthem
no more amer the star-spangled banner is
a divisive
topic okay cool if you want to if you
want to
protest and kneel during the anthem i'm
good with that
i'm good with the colin kaepernick thing
raise your voice
you know social justice i'm cool with
that but to the point of saying
no national anthem are you freaking
kidding me
do you know when like when did the
national anthem like really started
sports games you did some research on
uh world war one world war one right
okay so world war ii i'm assuming it
it was big for me being a kid i remember
i pledge allegiance at school ever you
know
1991 the national anthem who's hanging
at the super bowl remember that
whitney houston completely crushed
the national anthem we were in the
middle of desert storm
right we were at a war george w
bush senior i'm george bush senior h.w
bush
she completely crushed the national
anthem from that day forward i'm like
damn like i i get down with the national
anthem
now if you again if you want to protest
you have the right to protest
peaceful protest you totally have that
right you want to put your fist up
you want to kneel i'm good with that but
in under no circumstance in america
today
should it be even a conversation of
should we play the national anthem is
the national anthem the right thing to
do
if you don't want to be in america get
the out of america paul what do you
think
yeah i actually 100 agree with adam here
i was thinking the same thing
you at the end of the day you do have
the freedom to leave like it's just like
at a job if you don't like certain
things it's one thing to complain about
it
but at the end of the day you still
decide to be at that job
and you accept all the conditions that
occur with it if you don't like it go
find
another place you have that freedom but
you can't you can't have your cake and
eat it too
and like adam said the national anthem
is at the end that's kind of a that's
the
you're being in america you're accepting
that even immigrants that come here
you're accepting the national anthem
that's part of the deal
any any different opinion than what
we've heard so far any different opinion
thoughts mario any different opinion
than what he just said so far i mean i
just
give two cents here uh i think it's
interesting because
none no countries are perfect i mean
obviously there's there's um
baggage that comes with everything and
to to change
things completely like changing the
national anthem and traditions
i know we talked about traditions
yesterday of how changing
like people adjust to traditions
traditions traditionally don't change
based on who's there and you've talked
about this culture and companies as well
of there's a set culture and then
people don't change it either they adapt
to it or like you guys
have mentioned they can leave you know
here's
here's what i would say with this so
what you what you said everybody what
you're saying here is
uh nine years ago i'm at
uh malibu at this one private meeting
that was taking place and prager was
there
and dennis prager said what makes
religions
work okay and he's going through it what
makes people
go to so why does catholicism work and
you know do so
why is the judaism religion
you know he's going through everything
he says because of what the word
rituals right rituals there's certain
rituals
rituals you know i'm a christian but i
would go i
prefer to pray in catholic church i
think i told you guys yes i like to pray
in catholic church even i'm a christian
some people say you're out of your mind
why do you want to do that
that's me i prefer to pray at a catholic
church because to me
i feel a little bit more uh it's
different to me when i go there when you
go to a catholic church you know
there's so many rituals christians don't
have that many rituals if you think
about it
non-denominational evangelical not that
many rituals judaism lots of riches
christians have rituals don't get me
wrong but not at the level of
so then you bring your back and you say
okay america
mario uh when we came here mario was
staying with us for the first uh uh
couple days uh more like 20 but you know
he stayed with us here for the first
couple weeks and he's got a nice place
now right here
beautiful place he's standing right next
to coupon he loves his new bed by the
way
yeah i bet he does so so for for about a
week mario
what song did you hear me listen to for
hours
uh amazing grace how many times did you
hear me listen to it
honestly on repeat a couple hours every
night every night couple hours no joke
that was your go-to song everyone and
and what happened every time i listen to
it
you get emotional you have no idea how
emotional i get
listen to that song no no but there's a
specific song there's a specific person
anyways there's a playlist i listen to
it right and
you know it it kind of gets me to
think about how lucky i am incredible
life i have
all the screw-ups in life all the dumb
stuff i've done and i'm still forgiven i
still have the life that i have and
you've still been giving
me the life that i'm living today you
become the luckiest man alive
right so national anthem what's the
national anthem
you know the greatest country in the
world fought for this people that came
before us they did what they did and we
have the ability to sit here and we're
going to forget about that
and you don't want to play just because
you don't want to play because people
are offended okay
so he said the reason why we didn't want
to do it is because certain people in
our community
didn't want to hear the national anthem
certainly let me get this straight in
dallas texas
yeah who did that poll who did that
market research
you know how sometimes my employees
would come to me and you know
salespeople come to me and say
a lot of people are not happy with this
really name me one
they said really give me how many people
they are
and then it's always john and bob okay
so it's two people so don't say they
right it's two people how many agents do
we have eighteen thousand
two people say it we can't sit there for
two people you know so
so you you're living in dallas most
people in dallas are what love america
conservative hard working entrepreneurs
business owners
your ticket prices are not five bucks if
you are listening to a community
that you said they don't want the
national anthem to be played what is the
average income of that community
let's do the numbers why don't you make
your ticket prices
why don't you make your ticket prices
available to that community why don't
you make your ticket prices 10 bucks
why do you have ticket prices so
expensive if it's so much about the
community
stop selling 100 tickets 200 tickets 500
if you're so concerned about the
community
but if somebody's buying a 500 ticket to
come watch your game
200 ticket to watch your game for two
i'm taking my kid and i do that once a
year and you know twice a year
i'm making fifty thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars you're two
hundred thousand dollars here two by two
hundred dollar ticket if not by the way
i've never been to a basketball game in
my life i went to a basketball game as a
kid one time
and the star of that game was sadele
treat and tony smith you probably don't
even
remember those names yeah yeah number
three early night earlier
mid 90s but the point is nick van impe
the point is nick van axel was a star
that came a little bit after that but
here's the point i'm trying to make to
you
if you say your community doesn't want
the national anthem to be played
show us the report what percentage of
your community doesn't want to play
because let's just say that number is 10
percent yeah
say that number is 20 percent i can find
50 other things that 10 or 20 percent of
people are offended by you do what are
you going to do change again yeah
exactly so every single time a small
minority community comes out and says
well then we're going to have change
every single time i'm part of the
minority i'm middle eastern how many
middle easterners are in america
i'm a syrian i'm part of the minority
community i i don't have a four-year
degree i don't have a two-year degree
i am a minority i came to the states
green card got my citizenship a day
after i was in the military
what are you gonna do everything i
complain about you're gonna say oh my
gosh patrick's upset
no i have to work my way up have a voice
get my okay so i don't know look uh
there's there's two different types of
people you know people compare him and
trump together on you know mark cuban
and trump and all this other stuff by
the way yesterday you asked me a
question said if cuban ever ran would
you vote from what i tell you
so he runs against and i gave you the
roster who did i what did i say when you
said what if you ran against bernie you
said
uh cuban if you ran against biden you'd
say cuban cuban all day if you ran
against
trump you said i don't know what you
said no you didn't ask trump you said
you you said it
said you said pence oh ted cruz is where
you kind of were
i said i would be a little bit uh in the
middle because cuban at least
understands business but the difference
is the following what concerns me
he's obviously another future candidate
that wants to be a business it's a
movement right now entrepreneurs
becoming president you respect cuban oh
but there's things you don't
how do you not agree with how do you not
respect the guy okay first how do you
not respect the guy you go to indiana
university the guy's a ridiculous
numbers guy
an incredible sales guy learns to use
his numbers and sales together becomes a
billionaire
buys the maps brings the first champion
like there is
no i don't respect the guy i disagree
with this assessment of this situation
that's all it is
it's not there's no i don't respect the
guy for what he's done in his life he's
created a lot of jobs he's brought a lot
of you know
different things that he's done but i
don't know i i just think
uh we have to this will cancel culture
if it changes the rituals and what
america stands for
we're going to lose our values and
principles then america is no longer
america
no because america is just a land what
is america founded on
if it is let's just kind of keep
reminding ourselves that this is what
america is on sometimes we need and
you know what affirmation is affirmation
is what hearing the same thing what over
and over and over again i had an
affirmation list with 30
affirmations people would come to my
house friends of mine would come to my
house they'd be sitting in this place or
they take the affirmation they go to the
bathroom they say pat you got all these
laminated stuff on the wall they would
read it they're like man i'm fired up
because i have these affirmations and i
can tell you some of the affirmations
until today
we have to listen to national anthem
it's an affirmation yeah it's an
affirmation who we are it's who
we are and we listen to it over and over
and over and over my favorite service of
the year is christmas
you go to christmas you hear the story
at the end that they would put up the
candles he had one at the front all of
us would walk up
we would light up our small candle then
we'd go into our community then we'd
line up whoever's around us 5 10 15
people and all of a sudden you got
5 000 people with candle they would turn
off the lights he would just hold it
like this
don't let the candle drop on the floor
et cetera et cetera and you would look
at it like
this is awesome you know every year you
would go to like so freaking
ritual it's a ritual it's a reminder one
person can light up a country and
inspire them
so i don't know if this is a good thing
he's doing himself i'm glad that the nba
took their position by the way
phenomenal job shout out
for taking that position so it seems to
to just use the
cuban trump analogy and this is one of
the things that always frustrated me of
trump
and this is what cuban's doing right now
it's the
people are saying they people they're
saying
people are saying and and and i got to
give credit
i don't remember the interview that uh
jonathan swann the
i think he's british i'm not british uh
new zealand or australian reporter
they see sat down and did the one-on-one
he says who sang
tell me who saying yeah tell me tell me
who's saying what people are saying
it's so like i love what you said it was
with who's that well bob and john okay
so two people are saying
so that's what people are saying yeah
but by the way who did the research
we all do it when do we use that when
we're cornered
yeah yeah well i heard yeah but but we
already heard we all do that
but when we do it when we do that we can
still be held
accountable yeah also if you have an
argument guess what then you say
here's who said it okay fair i didn't
know then let's talk about it right
but if you say day people in our
community are not happy what percentage
of your people in your community
who is upset about the national anthem
according to such a easy way to bs your
way out of it i'm not
also the way in the interview how we put
it of oh we did we didn't decide
we're kind of just seeing how it goes
but now we'll go back to this
very safe answer of like of not trying
to play
he could be a president diplomatic i
think i can also yesterday on the
interview with
adam and robert robert was mentioning
that a lot of people
don't have financial education at the
same time i think
a lot of people don't know the meaning
of the united states flag
of the other or what we have done i mean
i come from colombia originally
so for me being here every time even
that i'm not
a uh an american u.s citizen born
here i always stand up and give my
respect to the flag
just because all the great things that i
have gotten for
coming to america so i just think that a
lot of u.s citizens
in high school i went to high school
here in the united states college
they don't teach us the value of what
united states of america of america
means
yeah it's and this is a guy that gives
yeah you know he
fought to come here from what did you
come here from 14 years old
14 years old you got your bachelor's
degree yes on your own dime
who paid for it i was working 46 hours a
week while going to school and what
degree did you get bachelor's and what i
have a bachelor's in
accounting and a bachelor's in corporate
finance how old were you when you got
the bachelor's in those two
hey i finished at 21. and how many how
much family you had here while you were
in
you know i have no family here no family
i mean that's that's the story
willing to go through by the way i do
want to respond to a couple people that
comment
that are against us okay i do want to
talk about that so here's
here's a one of the comments says uh do
you know the second stanza at the end of
anthem
it's offense to the people who built the
country air r
stop stop heart i'm gonna come back to
you because you had another comment as
well
adam i don't agree with you politically
but i'll listen to your financial videos
and want to say thanks for sharing your
wisdom matthew elliott okay thank you
chris hunter pat what are your thoughts
on general runs fired from mandalorian
also what are your thoughts on brian
rose running for mayor of london i
support brian i sent him a message i
said brian i wish you nothing but the
best him and i communicated
that's chris hunter but this is the
question stephen
kinonos francis scott key who wrote the
anthem
was a slave owner and most people didn't
know that
last that to last five years so what's
so that's what drives people crazy and
want to change
the america the beautiful soyboy mafia
hashtag so your community
yeah let me give the answer to that my
perspective just so you know
assyrians were slave owners blacks were
slave owners
jews were slave owners you go back 200
years ago 300 years ago
every culture on slaves
every culture on slaves there is not one
that never owned slaves
africa owned slaves they do many small
till today there are many countries that
own slaves what are we gonna do
so now we have to get rid of all the
history of everybody that at one point
had it is that what we're going to be
doing
so so what if right now somebody said
this one large insurance company that's
one of our competitors
and they've been around since 1868. okay
it's based out of new york hence
you okay so did you know
that back in the days they sold life
insurance to
slave owners so one of my guys said
we should use that when we're going up
against our competitors and bring that
up i said you're never going to do that
why because if they did it other people
did it
that was legal back then it was stupid
it was not good it wasn't anything that
we agree with today
but back then it was what legal
okay very simple legal and if it was
illegal back then no one is breaking
what
the law okay very simple so does it mean
we endorse it
of course not does it mean we support it
absolutely not
does it mean we sit there and we say oh
my gosh you know it's it's
so who cares no that's not what we're
saying it wasn't a law
back then so large insurance companies
uh what do you call it they sold
insurance to slave owners
should we shut all of them down all the
banks here
all the banks in america every single
one of them bank of america bank of
italy used to be bank of italy
so every single one of the banks in
america finance and help open up
accounts for slave owners should we shut
down all the banks
should we shut down all the bank that's
what we should do so every book you ever
read that's an old book
okay we're talking about 200 years ago
that are classics
oh somebody in their family should we
get rid of that book
so is this the direction we're gonna go
so so a crime everybody committed
now we should bring you back and because
of that embarrassed in public is that
the direction we're going
again that is a form of a nuclear war
because if you constantly go and say but
you did this
79 years ago but you did this 200 years
ago look at what happened kevin hart
who didn't want to see kevin hart do the
oscars who didn't want to see him as the
host
everybody wanted to see him do be the
host but no back in 2014 here's what
kevin r tweeted are you kidding me
and then they went through what they did
with kevin hart now so
to me it is part of the tradition it's
what we've used
everybody and anybody that we know on
their resume there is something bad
including yourself kenyon i bet you if i
were to go and do hire somebody 50 000
and i told them your project is to go
investigate to see what bad things you
did i guarantee we would bring out some
things that you wouldn't be happy with
i mean we're human we're not perfect
that's the point of us are perfect we
make mistakes that's just the way it is
what's that one song
i'm only human born to make mistakes
it's one of the best commercials uh and
i think another thing there is kind of
you're judging the past with today's
perspective and today's
uh values and principles that we have or
our viewpoints
right now which just doesn't make sense
because times
change things that are okay in the past
aren't okay now and vice versa things
that are okay now
aren't weren't okay then so you're just
you're confusing the times and how
you look at things and in that case
there's going to be wrong things with
everything i mean
again we're human we're not perfect we
make mistakes
and at different points in time those
things are okay or those things are
normal
watch this i can't hear him okay thank
you so what is february
black history black history month yeah
okay america do you know what percentage
of americans are african america
are african 13 exactly good number
that's the number 13.4 percent
do you know what percentage of our
company are african-american out of our
18 000
30 20 22 between 20 to 22
50 latino 50 latino 20 to 20
african-american right okay 20
white where we at you guys are up there
but they're like
top five no no not you guys but
but it's top five but here's the point
i'm trying to make to you does this mean
that we don't have you know 50 percent
of the company
to be white that we're racist again like
you understand what i'm saying like what
are you gonna do every time
you're racist against somebody every
comp you know like but
this sun this month is black history
month so the teacher asks my son
uh which character do you want to write
a report about
for black history month at the school
that he's going to so him and my wife
are having a conversation together
and my son says because my son has read
a lot of books on martin luther king any
book i get that i can give my martin
luther king i want
yeah tico i want him to read it so
he says i want to write about martin
luther king jen says
why don't you try somebody else because
everybody else is doing martin luther
king
he says okay he comes back he says you
know what mom i want to do it on rosa
parks
he said this yesterday he said okay son
so he's doing his report on rosa parks
hasn't how does he know about rosa parks
he's read multiple books on rosa parks
why because we want to teach him
the history of america we don't sit
there and say don't read this
you know read this here's what happened
given the band dude i went and seen the
real bus
of rosa parks that was i went to the bus
where it was in dearborn it's in
ford museum eric and i drove as we were
driving here and he got me a lot of crap
for this was because we were driving
through alabama
and i saw we were about to pass
montgomery and then selma was further
south so i was like let's just drive
through selma
and uh pete something bridge where they
the famous bridge where they marched
over it
we drove over it and kind of just
checked out the area so absolutely
there's there's a lot you can learn and
there's a lot you can
you have to kind of know of it to not
resp repeat the mistakes what's the
quote
those who don't read history repeat
history yep
adam i think even just what we're doing
right now
you're giving your perspective you're
giving your perspective i'm giving my
perspective
we all have different perspectives it's
important
i'm not saying you're 100 right you're
100 wrong it's important to talk things
out one thing that stands out to me
even on the podcast i remember when we
were during the middle of
all the protests george floyd they were
going down and removing
a lot of the confederate statues ruining
them all and you asked me a question
should the confederate statues
be removed and listen no fan of
confederacy
whatsoever like not even close um and i
give a very emotional
response and i hell yeah take them down
get the hell out of here
and people like what do you mean take
them down i'm like get them out get [ __ ]
them
and then after cooler heads prevailed i
listened to some other perspectives
i re-thought my perspective i
re-analyzed my stance of this i said you
know what
they should go in a museum for history
if you want to learn there's a
confederate museum over there we can't
cancel the past we can learn from it if
you're not if you don't learn from
history you're destined to repeat it
so i remember on another podcast i gave
uh a um
i reformed my answer and i said well you
know i thought about it
and i'd like to reverse course and i you
know i don't think they should just
remove everything but i don't think it
should be out there in the public
to be grandstanded on like these are
these people weren't heroes at the end
of the day they were traitors
but it is part of our history so put it
in a museum
you know if you want to learn about it
go for it so
what's important is to have a
conversation to hear your thoughts to
hear my thoughts
to hear the blm social justice thoughts
to hear
why you know the the south will rise
again hear their perspective talk it out
i did an interview with daryl davis
the most important thing you can do is
respect somebody's opinion
and be willing to listen you might
disagree but hear them out and when you
can talk to somebody
and you can have an open dialogue that's
where you'll find some compromise in the
middle
the cancer culture up get out you're out
go up but that's where we are though
that's where we are it's a very
dangerous life unfortunately that's what
we ask
i told robert kiyosaki i said we are
living in the walk and walking on actual
society
this is the walking dead robert f
kennedy just got cancelled off of
instagram if you want to put him up uh
permanent ban
uh robert all the way to the right i see
robert murray all the way up to the
right the link there you go
yep right there click on that okay so uh
instagram on wednesday took down the
account of controversial vaccine
activist robert f kennedy we removed
this account for repeatedly sharing
debunked claims about the coronal virus
or vaccine spokesperson for facebook
which owns instagram said in a statement
kennedy the son of the
late former u.s general u.s attorney
general u.s senator presidential
candidate robert f kennedy has
repeatedly spoken out against the
vaccine he has lobbied congress to give
parents exemptions from state
requirements that mandate their vaccine
their children look look what an insane
sentence that is
he has lobbied congress to give parents
exemptions from state requirements that
mandate they vaccinate their children
that's supposed to be controversial let
me read it one more time like horrible
that's supposed to be controversial he
lobbied congress
to give parents exemptions from state
requirements that
mandate they vaccinate their children
mandate horrible
that's that's supposed to be like a read
the next sentence though
the lifelong democrat downplays his
anti-vaccine views though by saying that
he is actually in favor of safe vaccines
and noting that all of his children have
been vaccinated there you go
kennedy's facebook page with more than
300 000 followers was uh
was still active at the time of the
publication the company spokesperson
said that there were no plans to take
down the page at this time
children's health defense the nonprofit
group kennedy chairs that expresses
skepticism about the health uh benefits
of vaccines that it could not
immediately comment on instagram actions
facebook has struggled for years to
crack down
um him and i had a conversation about
this a month ago he called me about this
a month ago because he was already
getting challenged
let me tee this up for your response if
you will because there's two stories
going on here obviously
uh big tech you know canceling people's
voices and then obviously
vaccine you held a vaccine debate with
robert kennedy junior himself and alan
dershowitz this was about three four
months ago
million views everything what were your
biggest takeaways from that debate what
do you recall from that
i look here here's it's two lawyers
robert is known as being an incredible
environmental lawyer
allen's a lawyer he's been a uh what do
you call it a uh
professor huge defense lawyers
defenseless constitutional lawyer for 51
years at harvard
obama took his class like that he's
defending trump these days he's defended
oj
his resume his resume is ridiculous okay
look i like a good debate because i
learn i sit there and i say okay this
makes sense so hey
well if you're doing this vaccine do it
after your kid's three years old okay
cool
the risk is when it's 18 months to 36
months okay that's good to know if
you're going through this
it's purely the option what what is
scary is the fact that you can't even
have the conversation today
like it's like a that guy said anti-vaxx
okay every single vaccine that
we've had to get we've gotten me
my wife our kids everything i've been
over vaccinated because i was in the
army when you're in the army you're like
uh what do you call it
you're you're a guinea pig they test on
you and you have this yeah you signed
saying weird things could happen to you
obviously a lot of weird things happened
to me after that but uh
so it makes sense yeah i think i think
it's uh it's a scary era we're going
okay and all of this started off with
one guy
being taken off of social media alex
jones alex jones
alex jones that's where this all started
that's where all this started well
someone like that rightfully so like
what's the
what's the line that you should cross
what's the what's the line you cross
where it's like
all right you've just gone from free
speech to
completely lying or giving false
narratives like you
you could say what you want but you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater
what's the line right
i mean this is the same thing that the
slippery slope people have been debating
for years i don't disagree i don't
disagree but
you mean to tell me like we can't have
technology right now that says on the
bottom
like you guys got billions of dollars
you mean to tell me you can't do a
technology right now at the bottom says
miss statement okay and it just comes up
that's all you have to do so imagine you
do videos that's all they had were over
trumps every single tweet no you did
yeah no but what i'm saying to you is
no it wasn't it was just a blanket one
everything he said it was blanket cdc
this
it was all blanket right the impeachment
is not this the electoral college is
yeah so beg to differ but but you just
have to show according to
give us the top 100 sources credible
okay and then say inaccurate statement
according to statistica this this that
right yeah it's awesome
so i'm like oh shoot we were wrong great
we did so are you saying that someone
can say whatever they want but as long
as they're fact-checked at the bottom
well yeah
what i'm trying to say is if we if we're
going at this level of advancement
just give us a source at the bottom
technology youtube whoever it is and say
this is wrong here's what the answer is
great now we know there's a form of
accountability and embarrassment quite
frankly
there's oh shoot i hate saying wrong
things oh my gosh my apologies guys
this is what it was so it gets people to
kind of be a little bit more careful at
throwing just
general statements out there right okay
so i don't know i'm not
uh i'm not comfortable with anybody just
being taken down
but nowadays for a guy who says he lobby
to get parents to have the ability of an
exemption
against mandated vaccines like that just
that sentence is a
but it's also labeling he's an
anti-vaxxer well no he was
questioning uh vaccines his argument was
in 1972 when i got the shots or my kids
got the shots it was three of them
today 72 six you know 60 some shots 70
some shots kids are gonna get
why do we go world that hasn't gotten
weight dirty or way more dangerous why
do we go from three to seventy shots
that a kid should get
that makes no sense that's what he's
arguing why do we go from three to seven
correct number that you find to be
i'm not an expert i'm not a doctor i'm
not a scientist all i'm saying is let's
keep debating
the topic of vaccines that's all i'm
saying well we have a doctor here dr
lude i mean your brother's going to be a
doctor i'm sure you have these
conversations
with uh with your fat brother cj
cj shout out trevor uh no i think were
you out with this guy i definitely think
uh
me myself i'm uh my mom never vaccinated
us or we've never been vaccinated
really yeah you're not vaccinated not at
all
um except
my my older brother and my older sister
they had to get some shots as they were
going to
med school actually interestingly enough
um so they were required and at that
point they chose to get the vaccines
they needed to
but i think i definitely i definitely
agree with what pat's saying that
there's
there's uh there's arguments that should
be had or debates and kind of seeing
how good or how is it because obviously
there's a there's a certain risk with
not getting vaccinated and then there's
a
there's a counter risk of getting
vaccinated can you guys do this be the
devil's advocate right now let's
let's try devil's advocate argument not
not that it's your position
make the case why it makes sense to take
him off of instagram let's all do the
devil's advocate thing
okay why did it make sense be the other
side i'm spreading misinformation that
is gonna
that it's gonna make people not get the
coveted vaccine therefore
more people will die okay good what else
is he specifically talking about the
covet vaccine or just vaccines vaccines
period but this year it also became
covert vaccine
why why does it make sense to take down
kennedy can i go a conspiracy theory
do it yeah go for it say it well if you
have an agenda uh and you're gonna
profit off
something and again i'm not saying this
is my personal belief but
if you have an agenda uh you know big
pharma is
a huge huge industry they're they're
lobbying
you know is some is the highest lobbying
in in washington dc
you're basically cutting off your money
so if people are now cutting off the
money supply
then that obviously affects
my business and i'm i'm the one paying
for your campaign paying for this so
there's there is ties and connection to
all that again whether it's true or not
none of us know but this is where you
really go into this
shady dark area of control
and and all that and if you start doing
the censoring and all that
like who's fact checking the fact
checkers right that's also another yeah
but i
i want their argument you're saying
ftm follow the money follow the money
that's the the number one rule in
journalism and it
it's the time it's
always stood the test of time is follow
the money okay adam do you have a
double zip i mean i i agree with him on
the follow the money thing i mean
why does it make sense to take him down
give the other side argument not what
you think
give the other side of the argument he
was taken down
they did the right thing because dot dot
dot misinformation
time whose money are you affecting
conspiracy theories
where are you going with this no i'm
actually i'm i'm not going anywhere with
this so
i don't i'm just really curious to know
the other side's argument
yeah it's just it's a scary situation
when you don't agree with some money
who's making the call all right that's
it you're done you're banned you're off
instagram you're off twitter
who are the people in the room having
that conversation but do you know is
there like a
a council like all right it's up at the
top now who are the three people making
that decision
what are they yeah what are their
political affiliations
where are they at who's in the room yeah
is it like the minority reporter where
are you
manager is it the uh look it's kind of
like going to
like it's kind of like who's making this
talk to kiyosaki yesterday you believe
save that money
yeah he doesn't he thinks it's waste of
money i asked him to say it he said i
will not say it
okay great so save that money right okay
no problem
so if you were to say make the argument
for the other side cash is trash
make the argument why cashes can we can
do that yeah why are they
give me an argument you're in the
boardroom we have to take them down why
because of da da da da da
what is it okay so you're stuck
what is it is it just misinformation and
conspiracy theory
is it obviously perpetuating what they
feel is the wrong
information you know who's perpetuating
pull up cnn's biggest advertisers
oh i'm sure it's all the big pharma
hello
cnn's biggest advertisers biggest
advertisers
keiko that's
what year though 2018 2018 is a
different okay let's just let's just
look at this
hotel or tesla oh tesla the premier lack
what do you know what the hell they do
but i've seen that commercial a billion
times okay
it's like the commercial where the
sleeping for the butterfly comes in your
room
i don't know i mean i'd also look up uh
uh
lobbyists for uh even body nor trump
yeah i don't i don't by the way it's not
like cnn took him down facebook uh
instagram took him down facebook took
over tesla is a pill that can help you
achieve clearer skin
or tesla is a pill that can give you
clear skin so it's kind of like
uh what is that one other pill that
uh helps you with skin uh uh accutane
yeah accutane
okay interesting okay i don't know i'm
curious
you know i'm curious to know what uh is
it just purely money is just purely you
know
let's get him out because he's an
anti-argument what are they
they are putting their points here
they're writing their stuff you know our
bodies heal themselves
you've got a fellow norwegian benjamin
kai i'm from they're putting their
points here so let's
say something to him in norway
okay let's continue let's continue here
on uh another topic that we got
uh countries most business-friendly
countries in the world
okay let's pull that up most business
friendly countries in the world okay if
we look at the most business-friendly
countries in the world
uh kai do you have a number on which one
it is
is the wikipedia one that one okay so
the easiest countries in the world to do
business in by the way look at this
every year they've been number one
except for 16 15 they were second
it said i'd love to before you say it
yeah poll the audience who they think
the most business friend maybe someone
who gets everybody up though
it's already up guys great job great job
everybody it's all right
number one for like 10 years straight do
you see that
do you see the singapore run and now
it's been new zealand the last four
years so it's a dog fight between two
people
new zealand new zealand and who was the
other one with that
that uh yeah it's really only two people
and hong kong is you know
top three top four there's everything
denmark
south korea us is number six united
states is
is consistently in the top however
however
look look at the ranking it used to be
number three yeah
so went from three to four to five to
four to seven to eight to six to eight
to six
okay so so it was a little bit higher
went to seven last year of obama went to
eighth first year of uh
trump okay then uh it uh dropped off to
six then eight and six so that's
regulation right there
okay georgia why would uh wow look at
georgia went from 100
in 2006 to sixth and seventh place
that's a big
jump that's reform right that's reform
and that's a government changing
uk uh about the same place they used to
be fourth in 2011 now it's eighth
norway uh used to be fifth now ninth
used to be eleven so relatively around
the top ten is where they are norway
look at china where is china's towards
the bottom of the list they're
highlighted in yellow
china i light it in yellow 31
yeah it used to be 91. that one's jumped
so yeah it's jump because well because
they are
allowed capitalism to take it's also
moved more towards capitalism as opposed
to it has the government communism but
uh
you can build your business and do what
you're doing yeah so then
so then go all the way at the bottom
let's see what's all the way at the
bottom like what countries are my people
in kazakhstan
armenia chile italy look at italy 58th
place mexico 60th india 63 but look how
much they've come up yeah they've got
130 they're
coming up as well uh keep going a little
lower mario
let's see what we see right there qatar
greece 79th
wow um galore lower lower lower lower
see if anything stands out at the bottom
with nations that we know about
guatemala mario you guys are doing good
from what's up
what are you doing in america
keep going brazil 124. uh
argentina 126 used to be 77 so they're
going the other way around iran
about the same place yeah it's been the
same place pretty consistently not good
for business
uh ecuador okay same place keep going
lower let's see what is like names that
you see
uh names nothing nothing uh
rising yeah iraq afghanistan where do
you see iraq 172
okay afghanistan 173. guys breaking news
it's
pretty tough to do business in
afghanistan and iraq
and syria as well if you're thinking
about starting a business
you're going to want to reconsider that
same with that as well as down there too
188 the worst country to do business you
surprised
our friends in somalia somalia okay go
to minimum wage minimum wage countries
before we leave this can we just go to
the united states i have one question
for you to get your perspective mario go
back up to you go back to that
to ease there's a one question on the
united states so we can move on to the
next topic
top of the list top five mario top five
why would the ease of doing business the
united states
be better more between 20
2008 and 20 you know 15 2016
and then when trump comes in and gets a
little worse
i thought it would be a little no that's
different it's gone from 3
4 to 7 8. who was president in 2015
uh trump 2015 no no that's obama that's
obama buddy oh bomb okay i got into
office in 17
obama raised it to seven and it hadn't
been at seven what do you mean he was
three and four his whole term
it was three before him in oh six he
doesn't get credit for three
i'm saying i'm saying eight nine ten
eleven
twelve that's thirteen he was three
three four he started what year did he
start what year did he start oh wait
okay what was it before he started
three yeah okay what year was it before
he started so he doesn't get credit for
three but he took a three and he
finished it with a seven
he took a country that was third best
for business in the world and by the
time obama was on it was number seven
you're saying from the beginning it was
no you were trying to make an argument
to like
you know no i'm saying it was consistent
it was between three and four the whole
time
prior to it and his last term and went
to seven it was three and four did you
pay attention in math class
pat i'm looking at the freaking numbers
here it starts as a three and it's a
three the whole time
is this math analysis is this basic
algebra i was a mathematician i won the
math elites i mean i know what i'm doing
here
he was a three to four the entire time
nobel prize
what's funny is adam was actually a 3.5
gpa guy
were you a three point six three point i
want to get it yeah yeah three six yeah
three six
were you really yeah in college yeah
were you being serious you should have
seen mine
yeah legit legit okay so yeah if you
take
if you start off and you're but trump
he's still doing this he's
trump is at seven through eight his
entire term but it's not like he went
backwards he went up
listen he started off with a seven yeah
when he left it was a what
six six and eight no six his last year's
ass he went from
seven seven eight eight eight eight six
he so he took a seven you don't change
rules and guidelines and all of a sudden
country doesn't change
it's bureaucracy he's patient
i think what he's trying to say is if
trump would have gotten a second term
maybe that would have gone to three
that's a good point or third that's it
that's that's about 13.
or 130. i'm just saying i'm shocked that
obama's numbers are that good
i thought they'd be worse obama's
numbers are terrible
what are you you're serious
is he serious obama doesn't get credit
for
what what happened in the beginning he
can't reverse things over here
was already a three prior to obama and
he kept it a three or
four what do you see he kept another
three or four
he gets elected in oh eight by the time
he's done in his first term it's a five
by the time he's done with his second
term it's a seven i mean you're like
crashing i thought i thought i thought
oh it was all without oh okay
obama obama is a terrorist do you want
to obama's
finances let me translate
remember foreign bill parcells took the
jets to the super bowl or the patriots
to the super bowl right
and they won the super bowl with bill
parcells the next year pete carroll
with the same team yeah they didn't they
didn't go to the super bowl
pete carroll doesn't get credit for bill
parcell's work
it went down that's the glasses talking
there's the glasses that's the glasses
down
like the superman glasses i feel like a
tom brady not even offend that right
there okay you want to go to the
batteries
okay so let's talk about batteries now
some of you guys by the way before
you're like oh my gosh who cares
if you're enjoying the conversation so
far and it's one of your first time that
you're joining us on this podcast
smash that subscribe button fyi i looked
at the numbers at the beginning remember
how i
ask put thumbs up if recall
for news thumbs down you know what the
number was after five minutes what was
that
200 thumbs up recall one thumb down
200 thumbs up recall i want to recall
the game they want to recall the guy
let's go to the batteries here okay
the battery uh is ready to power the
world okay
the flow of batteries is currently
dominated by asian countries and
companies nearly 65
of lithium ion batteries come from china
let me repeat that one more time 65
of lithium-ion batteries come from china
by comparison no single country produces
more than
20 of global crude oil output
65 this is an absolute monopoly
coming out of asia rechargeable
lithium-ion batteries were first
commercially used and held hand
camcorders in 1991 laptop soon followed
a decade later batteries enabled the
rise of tech titans such as apple link
by
powering smartphones and wearable
devices then made their way into
electric vehicles
the basic technology throughout
remainder pretty much the same lithium
ions move
through a liquid from the cathode to the
anode and back again
this however was just the beginning
after decade of rapidly falling costs
the battery has reached
a tipping point no longer just for
consumer products it's poised to
transform the way
the world uses power the gains are less
likely are likely to continue electrical
vehicles
vehicles are currently the main source
of demand for battery cells as event
grows
and the costs fall further batteries
will become even more disruptive across
industries battery industries score to
win at general motors
company would set it hope to phase out
gasoline and diesel-powered vehicles
from its showrooms worldwide by 2035.
the first commercially available etc
okay so kai tell us what's going on with
this batteries
and why should we be paying attention to
this um so obviously
just looking at the 65 percent it's a
shocking number that that's coming out
of g yes
so first thing i looked at then was
which countries have the biggest lithium
iron ores or the mines right
surprisingly
who would who would we think is on top
china exactly okay however china is
not on top on top you have bolivia
it's number one you have argentina's
number two you have
chile as number three by the way those
are some of the three worst
countries to do business with yeah so
you looked at on that list they're like
largely undeveloped yes they're not
doing anything well argentina changed it
they used to be up here yeah
they went a different direction three
south americans it was deemed as too
risky for financial investment
so bolivia argentina chile continue
fourth one
no none other than usa how many iron
uh how many lithuania lithium ores do we
have open
no one in nevada guess who hinted
at creating a second one in nevada who
none other than elon musk because he
wanted independence
not having to rely on others um however
number five is australia and then number
six
is china china has 5.
4.5 billion tons bolivia has 21
million tons or they're both in millions
however
the thing that is different is out of
all the countries china is the one
that's pulling the most
iron ore or lithium ore out of the
ground
other countries aren't so that's a
concerning however
another part of it is australia they
export
they exported 1.9 billion dollars
of uh lithium right most of it
went into none other than china
exactly okay so they're getting why
should we be concerned about this why
should we be concerned about the concern
about it is in some ways
just that they're they're they're
marketalizing they have
the control of it obviously we saw now
with uh the disruption in supply chains
that we have the struggle of getting
the chips that we needed and
self-sustaining kind of how we're
building things
another part of it is with the increase
in the electrical
vehicles and the batteries i mean
batteries moving forward are just going
to be more important
the reason oil has been a strong
commodity as long as it has
is it's easy to transport you put it in
a tanker
you you drive it wherever you want and
you drop it off it has the same
energy value and kind of efficiency
wherever it is
gas you can send it in in pipes and it
stays the same
batteries or especially electricity you
know the high voltage ones
they lose a lot of power when you're
sending the electricity so what you send
from a if you're saying 100
you're not receiving 100 on the other
end so batteries are the closest way we
can do that
and that is why if you look at tesla
the biggest thing they're doing is
battery development and figuring out how
you can store the energy
transport the energy and get the most
out of it later on
so that's i mean the future is going to
be in batteries because we need to store
the energy we
need to figure out how to do it as
efficiently as possible and obviously
china's leading the front on that end
the future is in batteries you just said
let me let me let me tee you up and tee
you up
you know how they say you know you only
remember you know
20 of what you see and 10 of what you
hear and
whatever the thing is but people
remember how you make them
feel how should people feel about this
battery stuff because i don't speak
robot i don't speak battery
i'm hearing like you know i'm hearing a
lot of math guys
yeah exactly for a mathematician i'm
hearing a lot of batteries i'm hearing a
lot of lithium i'm hearing a lot of
mining how should we feel about this i
mean there's
there's a reason for concern especially
if if things are being more
kind of split and uh companies
aren't being able to get as much from
china it's it's very easy
adam here's how you gotta look at it so
what perc
what percentage of the cars you guys got
to turn off your thing because i keep
hearing your audio you turn off your
speaker because i keep hearing
uh typing i hear it okay thank you so
what percentage of cars are going to be
uh uh battery driven cars in the next 10
years
a lot more than they are today 50 was
projected by 2040.
20 40 50 percent in the u.s 50 no 50 of
cars worldwide yes
okay so 50 yeah 50 worldwide by 2040.
and if will ferrell has it's going to
happen sooner than that if it's up to
welfare i know you guys are having a
service debate so but watch this
so if that's the case by 2040 yeah
who has control electric cars
okay so you remember when people said
why is elon musk shaking hands in
in china why is he doing by the way his
business is growing in china
there's a he's he's done a great job
being a diplomat
working with other countries trying to
get that part going yeah however
everything going in germany as well
however let me tell you what this means
in a whole different way
if this is the case and we need you know
import export guess what country cannot
have sanctions
with u.s guess what country cannot have
any kind of sanctions china
china so those sanctions need to be
lifted because
businesses behind closed doors such as
gm the tesla's everybody else gonna be
like listen
we need china they want sixty-five
percent of it you're shutting them down
you're hurting our business
we wanna create your costs you're
increasing the cost
you gotta open it up so look how it's
it's like the story okay let me tell you
the story so
um yesterday i was on a podcast girl
asked me and said
you know the the the podcast was called
uh women something about women what was
it uh women in business women in
business
something like that so she said what
what can women do
to be you know more uh you know
successful in business i'm like look i i
can tell you from my perspective on what
any person can do man or woman let me
tell you story
and this is exactly what china did so
there was a king
this king has a daughter he wants his
daughter
to marry a prince but this daughter
ends up dating a local
uh a guy and they get together and he
finds out about it
when the news gets back to the king that
the daughter ended up hooking up with a
local guy
the king sends his troops to go do what
kill the guy
so they go get the guy and everybody
tells him listen man you're about to get
killed
his people are coming after you're going
to die today they're going to kill you
they want to make a public example out
of you
this guy panics he's like oh my gosh
what are you talking about this is crazy
he says well you got to figure something
i do run away i can't run away that's
where i have everything
he said uh i have a plan it's okay
so he on the side was a psychic
okay where he would like do your what do
you call it like readings and all this
other stuff
so they come to kill him and says look
before you kill me i have some news that
i have to tell the king
the king has to know this and it's bad
for him but he has to know this as a
psychic i have a vision
and i've seen it i saw it yesterday he
has to hear the news
so what do they do well the king hey we
have to take you he wants to say this so
the king says come on before we kill him
i want to see what you have to say
he goes to the king and the king says
what do you have to say he says
well i had a vision i was reading and
seeing where you were at and what's
going to happen with your future
my prediction is you're going to die a
day after i die okay
so the king says what do you mean he
says whatever day i die
you die the next day so the king who's
an extremely superstitious guy says dude
we can't kill this guy
we got to make sure we give him the best
life so the king brings him in
hasn't married the daughter okay and he
says take care of him what ends up
happening
the guy outlives the king and the king
ends up dying
in this situation china's the psychic
[Laughter]
china has made it impossible to sanction
them
china has made it a monopoly to say i
dare you to sanction us listen what are
you talking about sanctioning us
you're going to need us long term and
they're sitting there saying
you taught us capitalism we brought it
in everything you did you allowed us to
take all your trade secrets we're
already so competitive it's so hard for
listen we're the number one you know
we're gonna win we're the future of the
world we're the future of the capitals
and we're the future of business every
innovation is gonna come from us because
you taught us but it's too late so this
entire battery game is a monopoly game
for china
congratulations china you have won the
game because that's the direction the
world is going
big victory for asian countries no
reversing
65 no listen
imagine you're playing a football game
the score is 65 to nothing
third quarter second quarter you're
gonna have to do a buffalo bill's
comeback
yeah we got to get tom brady on the
scene we've got exactly
matt ryan so that's kind of where they
have such a
long big lead who's going to come in and
try to compete with these guys
because if you think of it also as the
market obviously the market cap for
batteries and the need for it's going to
expand but they're just going to grow
with it
so the world is going moving towards
batteries and china's already there
saying come to my wheelhouse baby
what is this controlled by what is that
controlled by what's phone controlled by
what's the watch controlled by you're
saying
batteries are controlling big tech
batteries i mean they're the energy of
it
guys we learned something today here on
the bet david podcast batteries
but i think that's where investment has
to play a large role i mean you talked
about it's not like
they're the only ones with actual
lithium but which is the good thing
that's the great
thing it's a great thing but you have to
invest in that and we're talk like right
now we're talking about 1.9 trillion
dollar
you know uh relief bill it's not like we
don't have money
it's how we choose to spend our money
and we have to choose to invest
in our future and we're not doing that
when are you running for mayor i mean
that doesn't i should wear those glasses
more
that message the way you just said it i
i knew some i'm coming for you buddy
yeah ice cube for president paula scarce
and i endorse this message just say that
once paul say say it once
i'm paul scarce and i endorse this
message beautiful i i like polish
so can you go back to the top countries
to do business with and look at the top
minimum wage because we've been talking
about minimum wage we talked about a
little bit with norway
and the debate is norway capitalistic
nation a socialist nation
so let's go to the top minimum wage
countries is that the one or no
this is one of them yeah okay so so if
you uh
number one is that luxembourg luxembourg
okay what website is this world
worldpopulationview.com
okay go to the other one go to the other
one because that number seems lower than
what australia
is uh luxembourg has the highest minimum
wage in the world 13.78 13.78
okay uh uh uh uh
well that would only go to luxembourg oh
it's the same website okay so go back to
the website he had
luxembourg uh australia what was the
other website that's at 1260 australia
12 so i saw one that says 19 but it's
mostly
19 australian dollars which oh i got it
i got it so australia 12
and 14 cents their minimum wage france
1166.
by the way you're looking at socialism
right there then you got new zealand
1120 which was number one on business
friendly business friendly 1120 then you
got germany 1087
then you got netherlands 1044 belgium 10
38 uk 1034
ireland 962 canada 952 fyi china uh
russia is two dollars and forty cents
okay can you go a little lower mario
just to see
the u.s has the 12th highest minimum
range in the world at 725
at 7.25 it's important to say at 725
right okay
so if us goes to 15 bucks an hour
which numero uno in the world numero uno
in the world which by the way looks like
it's going to happen
because of the 1.9 trillion dollars the
democrats control the house the senate
and presidency and uh you know it's
going to be easy for that to be done
minimum wage goes to 15 bucks an hour if
minimum wage goes to 15 bucks an hour
and all the other countries we're
beating are socialistic countries what
does that say about america
[Laughter]
makes you think to say if there's an
area you don't want to lead is
minimum wage it's like look how amazing
we are we pay the highest minimum wage
go ahead two things with the minimum
wage i see australia is number two i
went to australia
2009 so a little over uh 10 11 years ago
and i remember uh obviously i got to
australia i landed i meet up with a
buddy
let's go get a beer let's go get a beer
let's go have a drink cool all right i'm
in the land down under i'm about to have
a beer
and uh we you know my i'm staying with
my buddy so
you know i do the right thing i pick up
the tab and pick up the check cool
guys yeah i know breaking news picked up
the tab i picked up the tab there it was
guys have you ever seen adam pick up the
tab yes actually yes
a cup once but what is this percentage
i mean with me it's very good but then
again but
but how many rides yeah who's the driver
so that's the exchange you got the pro
quo listen that's good
that doesn't that doesn't apply to
everybody else no i'm just lucky we roll
with pbd and
host everybody how many times have
people pay for pat anyway where's my egg
sandwich anyway
um mario's also very cordial what's my
point here what's my point where i wish
we had the button here
so i go to pick up a tab it's a hundred
year uh australian bucks whatever
and i go to leave a tip and the guy goes
no no no no
you don't you don't you don't need to
live a tip they're already good i'm like
what do you mean
in america you gotta tip 20 you know my
bill's 100 bills 100 bucks you leave the
waiter
you know bartender 20 bucks whatever he
goes no they're already
very well compensated i said what do you
mean they go yeah they make 20 bucks an
hour i said you're telling me
the waiters and the servers and the
bartenders are make 20 bucks
an hour you don't need to tip them no
you don't need to tip them
i said very interesting so it's that's
just a quick story and we can get a
feedback
but here's my here's my segue back to
pat
you know because i would consider myself
much like mario an entrepreneur
i've helped build businesses but i'm not
the business
owner i'm not the founder i've built
built
up a business and made a business very
successful but i'm not the owner
same thing we're doing here with
valuetainment but we were reading
yesterday about the 15
minimum wage hike what's going on here
and potentially in america
and and pat said how do you feel about
that i said you know look i'm i've come
out vocally i'm not
in favor of a federal mandate of a 15
minimum wage
i think that's absurd across the board
in certain states or cities
new york city san francisco miami
whatever cool i get it
you can't live on less than 30 grand a
year if you're going to have
a life but if you're in tuscaloosa
alabama if you're in
you know bumble f oklahoma like
businesses you know i don't i'm not in
favor of that
so i that was my perspective and i asked
pat your perspective and genuinely pat
says
i am so sad
i feel so bad for these businesses you
have no
idea how bad i feel for the i'm i
i'm genuinely hurt for these businesses
and my thing was more logical zero
emotion
in my answer i said well i just don't
think it makes sense economically
financially
pat came from a place of obviously logic
first and foremost
but deep sympathy for these businesses
and i said i don't
feel that sympathy that you're feeling
and you said well that's because you've
never started your own business
i said what do you mean by that and you
said when you start a business
you know you now you know maybe this is
where you want to pick up
but you had very strong feelings about
this minimum wage it was more like it
was more emotional than logical how'd
you feel
well you know listen go to
go to the example i gave you when i said
adam let's just say you and i fight
no because you went to say when a person
starts a business don't they already
know that you may lose it yeah that's
that's what the conversation went i said
you put your you know you risk
everything to kind of put yourself out
you know what you're getting yeah into
and i said
yes except when the rules change that's
when it's unfair so if you and i were to
fight there's a big fight coming up
yeah patrick's fighting adam on june
28th major announcement you're a better
buyer
i'd pay for you're a better person
you're a better boxer you're a better
boxer you're an eight i'm a six and a
half i have no clue how to box
but you're a much better boxer than me
much better fighter than me
and the rules is we're gonna fight what
boxing
but i'm a ridiculous kicker if i kick
you you're over three kicks
fight's over okay that's me i'm a nine
you're a one when it comes down to
kicking
five minutes before the fight they say
rules have changed you cannot kick
who wins that fight i win the fight
because i don't even have to come close
to you i can't have a distance from you
my legs are longer than your punch so i
won the fight okay
so you're mary you're on a small market
that your father passed down to you you
and your husband run it together with
your kids it's been around for eight
years in a small city
and you have walmart right across the
street but you've still been able to
survive because walmart sells milk for
you sell milk for 349. they raise the
minimum wage
six of your employees that work for you
you pay them 720.
okay eight of your workers i worked you
paid them 720 some of them 10 bucks an
hour but not 15.
so they raised the minimum wage to 15.
you have to raise the milk price from
349 to 429.
walmart keeps it at 359. you
have to raise the employee's minimum
wage from 720 from 10 bucks an hour to
what
15 bucks an hour walmart doesn't care
walmart loves that
the government officially eliminated you
without walmart becoming the enemy
a 15 minimum wage makes
this small business owner go out of
business without walmart even needing to
compete
right walmart says cool pull it up like
it's like the fight happens
and the referee said fight hasn't even
started referee says adam you won
and what are you talking about we
haven't started adam won the fight
that's over that's what just took place
right now
think about it this way okay minimum
wage
what industry pays
the most employees minimum wage let's
look at it do we have that data we don't
have that data
no we have okay pull up the data pull up
the data kai where's that data wait
uh there's one which is the uh no we
might actually not have this one but we
have the chart
uh if you go here the one that says here
the tab that says here where is here
okay right there okay good
you'll see here are this is for leisure
and hospitality that's not what i'm
looking for i'm looking for can you
search mario which
industry has most minimum wage employees
by the way the number is staggering
the difference between first place and
second place makes zero sense
which in the audience want to guess what
industry oh you can guess
while we're pulling this up you're about
to be shell-shocked which
industry has most minimum
wage let me see if i can find it more
you do it as well employees see if you
can find it i know i searched it
yesterday
uh and it was a okay now
oh my gosh if we can show you this this
is okay i found it here we go
i find it's a statista website uh
can i share it with you airdrop or
you're not on a mac you're on a mac okay
airdrop
which mac are you on i have it's
valuetainment media
by tim and mack is that the one yeah
okay mario see if you receive it
you got it okay i'm gonna press it again
okay open it up accept watch this look
at this
look at look at that i'm not even close
get rid of that
you feel free yeah oh my how come it's
not
oh there you go okay go up a little bit
it's not letting you see the uh
are you kidding me because i have it
over here okay well anyways you see that
first one
i'll just tell you what it is you see
the first line the first line is
leisure and hospitality yeah you know
what the second one is education
977 by 149.
seven times higher okay
so let me get this straight leisure and
hospitality
has the most employees making minimum
wage and
which industry got crushed
during covet the most the last you just
crushed these guys yeah you just
destroyed them and if you go to the
last chart you can see what jobs have
lost the most mario bring up where the
jobs are
um another interesting part though is
that that is also the industry where
people are most tipped in legionnaires
so that obviously makes up for their
wages in that sense of that there's a
there's the
there's the minimum wage and then
there's the tips they receive as well
everybody took a hit with that the
customer because food price is going to
go up too it's going to go down
tip's going to go down food prices are
going to go up and
what's that uh here the one the tap to
the left for that mile
we get that one leisure and hospitality
they are down the most in january i mean
they've been crushed the entire pandemic
but even january
they lost the most jobs so you know it's
like imagine you're running a small
restaurant you're like okay oh we're
going to come back oh my gosh we have 38
in our account dave we're going to make
this work guess what
minimum wage so then imagine that
meeting with you and your employees
your waiters and your waitresses you're
having a meeting with them you got four
of them sitting in front of you
how do waitresses feel about the minimum
wage being raised from 725 to 15 bucks
how do the waiters and waitresses feel i
mean well
how many how many are sitting there
there's four four of them well now
congratulations you've been with me for
five years
there's only three of you now someone's
getting but actually give me their
feeling
how are they feeling about going from
seven 25 to 15 bucks
exactly they're not against it they're
for it are you kidding me dude
what are you talking about do you not
remember what like i had a job for 325
at hogan does
when i got a race to 5 15 at bob's big
boy i'm like dude i'm going to be
rolling getting a nice freaking telestar
pager and i'm going to be able to send
the hello text and the double beeper you
know all this stuff it's going to be
sick right from 375 325 to 550.
if your waiters and waitresses are
sitting there for them they're going
from 725 to 15
minimum wage you think they support the
minimum wage hell yeah hell yeah they do
you think you
the business owner that now have to sit
there and say
guys we got to do something about this
yeah do you think there's a division now
between the employer and the waitress
i mean compensation-wise at that point i
feel like they're also dipping into tips
at that point you can't though legally
you can't do that you can't do that
legally no no no you can't
you mean really you want the restaurant
to take tips off you can't do that
you you one restaurant gets reported
that the owner keeps tips you're over
nobody works for you obviously you're
not doing not taking the hundred percent
but you're making enough for not do
anything really you cannot do anything
it is the fastest way to not have
waiters and waitresses work for you is
what
is when you keep tips a percentage of
the tips it's the fastest
i think the house twice as much to begin
with doesn't matter that's not how
things work
that's not how things work so guess what
they pulled a typical burger you go to a
nice restaurant a burger is what 15 16
bucks
a nice restaurant i'm not talking about
like you go to burger king
nice restaurant you go to like what
gary's is that gary's uh what is that
place we go to here right here we were
there yesterday with the crispy
zucchinis
gary's uh gary's farmhouse right here in
boca by
meisner his burger is
uh 16 bucks 17 bucks they raised the
minimum wage his burger is now
20 at least 22 bucks 23 bucks
ain't nobody paying 22 bucks for a
burger soda is a buck fit or you will
pay for it no
you will i mean the businesses as well
you won't pay for it
whoever's covering your check will pay
for it
but someone's paying for it 22 burger at
what point is that just ridiculous it's
not about instead ridiculous you have no
control this is not something they're
asking you for your vote
the senate the house and the president's
passing this law
and they're putting it in the 1.9
trillion dollar bill you don't have a
choice you don't have a say
just take it this is what's happening
here okay so yes that's what's going to
happen
leisure and hospital as if they didn't
have one black guy they just got a
second black guy
i saw something on uh prageru on their
instagram uh
they did a little bit where it's like
all right guys congratulations there's
four of you in the room
and uh made announcement uh uh minimum
wage has been uh
increased up to 15 so let me tell you
what's going to happen to the four of
you
uh john congratulations you have a raise
sally congratulations you ever raised
nancy congratulations you have a raise
bill pack your [ __ ]
time for you to go bud you got to go so
the four has gone down to three
and the the rest of you will just be
doing more work
uh for uh 15 an hour and congratulations
on everybody on their uh
new jobs and uh get the hell out of here
yep yeah by the way
somebody just said here right now they
said pbd it's called gratuity and they
do it all the time
dante i know i get that and this one
person said florida has had a
15 minimum wage florida has 15
minimum wage in a couple of years it's a
done deal anyways meaning the 15
minimum wage right yeah you must order
yesterday's podcast though
you must have missed yesterday's two
days ago podcast i said states like
florida
texas california new york
forget about it 15 bucks is it's
mandatory what are you talking about
thirty thousand dollars a year not for a
job
that's how much you're making on fifteen
dollars an hour just times it by two
this isn't about florida america is
bigger than florida california and new
york and texas
yeah america is bigger than that all
over all of the flyover states that
everyone forgets about it
my concern is a small market you know
how when people say things like the
argument is
well do you think it's fair that a
company like walmart came and crushed
all the small businesses and put them
out of business
yes they didn't do it by themselves they
did it with the help of the government
regulations yeah they did it with the
help of government that's that's how
they do it they didn't do it intent
they got some help to have some like
that take place so yes i am with you
and i hope some of these businesses find
a way to
survive specifically in the leisure and
the hospitality we got 15 minutes left
12 minutes left let's see oh let's see
what we want to cover that we haven't
covered yet
do we want to go market uh new york
opening
salesforce salesforce let's talk about
salesforce let's talk about salesforce
so salesforce is on what page tell me
what paid sales 4004. everybody turn
your uh
turn your syllabuses your syllabi bibles
to page number four
yeah i think this is a very interesting
topic okay hang on one second
i don't know if we're gonna have time to
talk about your favorite thing dogecoin
but
just know that salesforce says the nine
to five work day work
day is dead they will provide three ways
to for employees to work including
working from home salesforce on tuesday
now said its employees would have the
option to work from home
remotely full-time even even when it's
safe to return to the office the new
guidelines which sell forces calling the
work from anywhere offers employees
three options uh
flex fully remote office-based
salesforce says the decision to offer
new ways of working was based on
employees well
wellness survey the company had been
sending around since the onset of the
pandemic okay so guess what
they sent a what a survey something more
cuban ought to do
something mark cuban ought to do for
employees who work within the flex
option they'll report to the office
between one or three days each week for
tasks
that are more challenging to do over
video calls such as team collaboration
customer meetings and presentations
salesforce said it's most of its
employees
worldwide would have a flex schedule an
immersive work schedule
workspace is no longer limited to a desk
in our towers the nine to five work that
is dead the employee experience is about
here's the big part pay attention here
though pink punk tables and snacks
that's a shot straight
at you it's your number one
it is a shot at vt brent hyder the
president of the chief police
uh people office of salesforce said that
salesforce
okay so what do you think about this
what do you think about the direction
sales force is going do you agree do you
disagree with them well this guy mark
benioff
has clearly proven himself to be a
leader uh in the business community yeah
i got a lot of respect for this guy
salesforce uh
you know they they they start trends
they don't just kind of follow them
they've come out and said
wfa is a lifestyle now baby wfa work
from anywhere
and you have three options who's in
favor of three options we're in favor of
three options around here what do we got
what do we got you got this flex
schedule
you come in the office a couple days of
the week you work from home a couple
days a week
do what you got to get done you got the
fully remote
we never even see your ass you're just
you're working remote
you want to get a big time job this guy
actually lives in uh
indiana uh typically we couldn't get
this guy in here but or a gal
we're gonna have him work a remote from
indiana let's bring in some talent
let's pay them what we got to pay them
they're working fully remote and then
there's obviously office base
but the beauty right now is we got
options
you got options options that didn't
exist per se
before this pandemic so basically mark
benioff ceo of salesforce is saying
listen
the nine to five is dead i think we can
agree right here nine to five
is a very old school mentality when it
comes to work
show up you know sit sit at your desk at
nine o'clock
take your lunch at noon be done by 12
30. you know
after that you gotta you know the people
what do we what's the joke that you make
the 459 crowd what's the joke that you
make for them
459 they are they are standing up and
stretching they are out the door we got
blueberries running wild here
but the the most beautiful thing that
you can do and everyone does it here
at valuetainment is you show up when you
show up
you leave when you need to leave and
your gsd you get your [ __ ] done
okay and for the nine to five crowd you
know who you're making your salary
you're making your 30 or 40 grand
whatever whatever whatever
the people get stuff done they don't
necessarily abide by nine to five you
come and you and as long as you enjoy
what you're doing
you'll work from anywhere you work
remote and i just think it's impressive
that he's giving the people the options
now and i think that's the future of
what do you think
i mean we've seen this in silicon valley
and i think to in essence i'm agreeing
with what adam's saying here
of the options um it also depends on
obviously the work that they're doing
some things you can't do uh
and some things you can do remotely in
the in towards the end he also mentioned
that it obviously widens their pool
for talent which is another thing but i
also think
that if if the work if this is truly the
way things are moving
then virtually how would would you as
somebody
stand out more as opposed to like in an
office i mean you're you're a ceo you're
a founder
how would somebody that's one place
where i can see an issue is like how do
you efficiently
stand out or become more of a linchpin
if you're just kind of
so here's mike here's my question for
you so maybe we
ought to forever only watch video games
through zoom
not video games sports sporting games
like nbas we should not go to games
anymore
why why do we go to the game why don't
we just watch it from tv
what's the difference from going to yeah
then actually watching it from tv
maybe we should drop school and no
longer have to go to school and
everybody
just goes to school from home on a zoo
maybe we should do that maybe we should
do that
i don't like that wait a minute why not
what's the maybe maybe moving forward
church should only be from home you know
not not going to a actual place a
sanctuary a church maybe we should just
do it through zoom and somebody preaches
and you just kind of you do worship from
you know from home and not go to church
and we just kind of do
maybe maybe super bowl there should be
no fans in there you know maybe
maybe all-star game there should be
nobody in there you know where lebron
says i see no reason for us to have a on
the all-star game
fans not going to be there so maybe
maybe everything we should do we
shouldn't be around each other anymore i
think it's a bad idea maybe we should do
that maybe that's the direction to go
because
we don't really need human interaction
you know we can do it through zoom
i mean talking to my dad over phone is
the same as seeing them face to face
right
that's what it is what's the big
difference i mean who cares about a hug
who cares about a handshake who cares
about how you're doing
that's not that valuable you know who
cares about sitting down here having
this kind of a conversation we should do
this from a zoom you should stay home
why are we guys here
we should do a podcast from home you
shouldn't be here right now we shouldn't
be doing it this way
why do we come over here to work people
forget
this is human beings you're talking
about how the hell do you build the
culture
working from home how do you do it how
do you build a culture why
why do you go to a concert ask somebody
who went to a michael jackson concert
what they'll tell you
they talk about it till today ask
somebody who watch michael jordan play a
game score 45 points on a sunday
that everybody else was watching on tv
and they were there ask somebody who was
at a game when reggie jackson had three
home runs in the game mr october
what did it feel like when you were in
there versus somebody that watched it on
tv
ask somebody who was there when doug
flutie threw that touchdown for boston
college what's the difference between
that and the highlights we watch on tv
look i'm not sitting here saying certain
industries this works for
okay i have a chief information officer
guy that works with us he says pat
here's how engineers
are very good very a guy i trust he's
very
uh the way he explains things is my
style
i like it a lot and for
engineers i get it yeah they're wired in
a different way
everything else i don't know it doesn't
apply 100 to every industry this is not
a black and white across the board
everybody you can't do it that way
because you can't build a culture that
way for example
video game if you want to have a a video
game
competition can you do it from your
house sure fine
can you do a poker tournament from your
house okay fine
is it different than you watching the
world series to everybody sitting at the
table
not the same when you're watching them
talking to each other all this i can't
see your eyes i can
it's a very different story we
human beings are not robots
we human beings have emotions
we in human beings have feelings we
human beings have different senses
and those senses are only being used
when you're around what
others you can say all this stuff you
want and
give me a great pitch on it that this is
the directions going everybody can work
from home forever
fine do it it could work for some
companies
can't work for everybody and then the
idea of culture so
if you were to say what is the biggest
company in the world today that people
talk about
culture what's the company that's
culture culture culture culture culture
google
that everybody netflix netflix oh yeah
reed hayson said i'm not a fan of this
he's not a fan of working from home
forever why not
when you think about culture does
anybody ever says the sales force
culture
no they have a great product they have a
genius run at a company
but when you think about netflix what do
people say they have a great culture
what did jobs say about culture what did
growth say about culture
what did anybody that ever built an
incredible company say about culture you
kidding me how do you build culture
through zoom
how do you do it there's nothing like
face-to-face building culture so i
i i'm not sitting here saying i disagree
i'm not sitting here saying i
i think that is the direction we're
going i think some of the industries yes
but if you want to build a culture it's
going to be very very
difficult trying to do it all from home
we have some people writing on the
company all we do is zoom we don't do
trainings anymore
really yeah they're being left behind by
others who are doing
face-to-face they can do what they want
to do based on the guidelines of
whatever the state offers
we're just going to do zoom moving
forward we're not going to i'm going to
go out there and live over here and i
don't even need to be on my office
fine you know what we've noticed
happened to their business last six
months
gradual decline then the people that are
together seeing each other office
and we know what we notice with them
gradual increase
how do you measure that you know you
have certain players in the mba
that you can't measure their statistics
you can't measure draymond green
you just cannot measure him but how much
does he do for the game
a lot you can't measure patrick beverly
okay but how much does he do for the
game a lot you can't measure a lot of
the stuff rodman did
and it's not just rebounds he didn't
score but what did rodman do
oh my gosh none of that stuff has a
leader's bulletin
how he had karl malone dropped four
times on the same walk back
you know after you know you know which
one i'm talking about finally he got so
upset annoyed and caramel couldn't make
the shots because all he kept thinking
about is how annoying who is
dennis rodman is yeah so the point i'm
trying to make tangibles
the intangibles you cannot discredit the
intangibles just
because the intangibles don't show data
you have to pay attention to it and i
don't know if a lot of people are paying
attention to it this is too early this
is too early for us to jump to
conclusions saying
this is the one way to go that is the
one we still haven't seen the side
effects of it it's still going to take
us a year or two years three years for
somebody to have a definite philosophy
these are all testing philosophies cove
it's only been around for a year it's
not even many years
i mean of course we're in the middle of
it right now things are going to a year
since the first death let's just say
it's been around the years 12 months
it's one year old yeah
shutting down as a year old we've not
experienced shutdown before
so a question more of a follow-up yeah
but this isn't this
you know the truth is always somewhere
in the middle you know
not you know doing zoom non-stop and not
showing up in person
is obviously a ridiculous non-human uh
it just doesn't make sense but only
going to work
everyone doing that can be oftentimes
inefficient that's why i'm saying i'm
i'm in favor of this flex
option like you guys like you guys put
on big events you guys have meetings
php obviously valuetainment we're here
but you guys
also utilize a lot of zooms zoom has
helped your business immensely i never
discounted it no so i'm saying so like
there is truth is somewhere in the
middle here zoom to me is speed
zoom to me is not culture so remember
how everything to me is a ward like if
you want to talk about
people who like to control people why
are they controlling them controlling
trust right lazy is what
you know boredom you know you got the
bitterness is what
lack of creative you're not creating
anything you're not part of a community
okay
when i think about zoom i think about
speed speed that's all i think about
i don't think about culture i don't
think about culture but they're
they're they're those are all important
elements to a business i don't disagree
that
is important but culture is probably the
most important but that's
pretty damn important is very important
but if there is no
uh okay so uh uh have you ever had a
long-term long-distance relationship
yes what do you say to a person who says
i love her but we see each other once a
quarter
what do you say to that quarter that's
ridiculous what do you say we see each
other once a month what do you tell them
bro like how do you what do you do the
rest but that's right wait a minute what
happened to you all of a sudden you
flipped
we're zooming every day though
uh-huh no that's relationships come on
now
what is culture all right all right
let's see where i see where we go oh a
little bit tipping point right there for
you huh the moment it got to
how are you gonna have you ever had a
long-distance relationship
yeah but not not i would not see someone
once a month for
an extended period of time then it's not
a long-distance relationship buddy what
do you do you see them once a week you
fly out to them and see them once a week
no it's not sustainable i think that's
where you're going yeah that's zoomed
in long distance relationship is zoom
yes kai what's your point
no i think i think pat has a lot of good
opinions and kind of
input there but i do think also that
it's
changed the way where it's now more
flexible like
get kind of going back to adam with
flexibility and also realizing that
the business trip everyone thought
everyone had to do 100 of the time
they realize now hey that like what if
we cut back half of those times
we move that money someplace elsewhere
where we can get more return for it
i think that has changed and probably
will stay that way for quite some time
even though things ease up and
restrictions and stuff like that because
they're kind of realizing
what is necessary but then also a lot of
the stuff that isn't necessary
i don't disagree i think the flex is
here i think uh uh i think
believe it or not i think covet hurt
commercial real estate
yes but i think covet also hurt a lot of
universities
you know what do i need to stay on
campus now okay what is the purpose of
going to college
if you actually think about what the
hell is the purpose of going to college
yeah i have i have friends in norway
school in the us i want you to think
about this actually process it
what is the purpose of going to college
if you have kids right now what is the
number one reason you would want your
kids to go to a great college well
everyone has always said the college
experience which is why right
you know you're going to you're going to
parties and frat and going to class and
you're
all that but now if you're just zooming
what's the college experience
but you said that's a good idea though
saying there's there's a
i'm in favor of somewhere in the middle
there's a flex gate so only 50
of students should go to college
everybody else zooms in
no i'm saying you can go to classes
on campus but also you know do i need to
commute and i i'm just saying a
hypothetical commute an hour
to take a two-hour class to drive back
home an hour it's like dude let me just
zoom for this one
colleges just got crushed i'm in favor
for that it's fine
eliminate 40 of them keep the 60 that
can handle it
what happens there then again college is
about experience
people relationships yes seeing what's
going on learning how to communicate
with people learning how to do soft
skills not just hard skills
i think i think you've been watching the
movie with uh joaquin phoenix
heard too much lately and i think you
got to stop watching that movie her have
you seen her
paul has anybody here seen her you've
never seen her
have you seen her you know what the st
what's the story about
he's basically he builds a relationship
with his smartphone
so it's him and his smartphone and they
pretty much get into it he falls in love
with
her it's like you [ __ ] hey siri how you
doing
hey baby wait
hey siri how you doing not too shabby
thanks for asking that's my series why
is he all serious sounds like he's a
joke that's nice
he's an engineer he's a joke that's my
that's my siri right
okay hello patrick big david good to see
you again
i think the direction we're going is
adam's going to have a uh
uh virtual reality all you heart hot ass
smartphones out there holler at your boy
i'm here
it's going to be the situation i'm
dating somebody who can we see or not
yet can we see her not yet not yet not
yet i'm trying not to she's from germany
though
[Laughter]
anyways hey if you enjoyed this and this
is the first time you're joining us
smash that's a
subscribe button uh we are not having
any podcasts over the weekend next
tuesday we are going to do one i believe
it's going to be tom's going to be in
town tom's back
tom will be in town and then i never
thought i'd say these words but i'm
excited to see tom
good that's good dash had a accident
with his anger
is a stud man you can't stop that guy
that guy's going to take mess up that
face
dash nah the face is not going to get
messed up he's a brad pitt looking
kid that's going to that's going to
excel in life he's he's two
too handsome too handsome and pretty and
he's a stat but anyways tuesday
next week same time 8 am eastern
standard time
have a wonderful weekend everybody we'll
see you guys next week take care bye-bye
you